[Music]
hello and welcome to
my review of maple syrup i made pancakes
but i made them before i started the
video
however i knew that some of you would
want to see me make pancakes so i
actually got footage of it so here it is
all right there you go hello and welcome
to my review of all of canada's maple
syrups this may or may not be all of
them
but i'm gonna get to that that's not the
point right now i'd like to start off
this video with an apology to the
canadian government
and to an individual known as eve harlow
lexian put up an artist's rendition of
eve harlow right here
like your your artist rendition of eve
harlow right here
make it somewhat flattering take exactly
10 seconds to make it though
we don't have a lot of time eve along
with leo and franz
are joining me as we film the edge of
sleep the tv show along with
many other people who are in the show up
here in canada which is why i'm here but
not the point of this apology
i'm making this apology because i told
eve that i do food reviews sometimes or
other reviews
it's not just food
and i said that i might be wasting it
because even though in food reviews i
tend to try to donate what i don't eat
to food banks
if i open a container it makes it a bit
more difficult to do so
because of food safety and food laws and
stuff like that
however this did not fly with eve so i
made a promise that i will be using
every single drop of all of this
in a gratuitous amount of granola
cooking that i'm going to be doing
lots of granola i only know about
granola she also sent a
cookie recipe but i'm not sure about
that but anyway i just wanted to make
amends
and also mention an organization known
as food not bombs
check that out or various food banks
around you to provide
for your community with that out of the
way i would like to now
move on to my challenge of the canadian
government and a renegade individual
known as eve harlow here is a police
sketch rendition of eve harlow lexie and
just like
use the same sketch as before but add
some like antagonistic features right
who the hell do you think i am do you
know what they call me back in
america i'm known as mr
buttersworth lixian play the footage of
me being known as
mr buttersworth and you better know
where that is
you better know mark mr
butterworth fridge buck oh yes
that's true that's right i'm mr
buttersworth and all of your fancy maple
syrup and all your infatuation with
the maple tree and the maple leaf
it's awesome we get it you love trees
but down in america we
love our pancakes with nothing more
we love our pancakes with nothing more
than good old-fashioned corn
that's right corn syrup with butter mr
buttersworth doesn't have any kind of
reservation
about only having not the best for mrs
buttersworth
and all i need for that to do that what
i do is corn
i am basically 90 corn at this point in
my life
you think i'm gonna get a tree in there
with it i don't think so
that would be over 100 and i ain't about
that because the body is 70 percent
water and if i'm 70
water and 90 corn what does that leave
for maple negative 60
and i'm not about that anyway i'm going
to try this and i think it's very good
i do like maple syrup i will get that
out of the way let's get the entirety of
whatever the hell that intro was
out of the way and let's move on to the
goodness this is maple s
this is this is maple syrup
focus is it folks this is maple syrup i
actually
recognize this jug of maple syrup i've
seen this before
this awakens something in me
it doesn't awaken something in me but it
conjures up some memories
it awakens some memories in me this does
not
has not awakened am i rolling
yes when i said i was going to use every
single drop of maple syrup i
meant that but not in the way that you
think i'm meaning
unless you're talking about granola
anyway i have five here a varying
different levels of fanciness
i have 100 pure maple syrup syrup
apparently in canada all packaging has
to have both english and french i did
not know that
this one's kind of an orangey this one's
more of a dark
kind of almost black color this is pure
maple syrup
canada grade a very dark strong taste
i'm interested in that that sounds
pretty good
they all say 100 i don't know how you
can have 100 maple syrup and also have
one that's a stronger
taste i don't know about that and then
we have
this one which is le epic it's more
french than the other one i guess
we have the jug and then we have this
one which is like a
freaking whiskey bottle of maple syrup
it's the president's choice the
president chose this one so i'm gonna
save that one for last it might be great
it might be terrible
but i really like the color and the
bottle's really cool however it was way
more expensive than it should have been
probably
and i don't know if it's gonna make a
bit of a difference here here's the
pancakes
because i know this one first i'm
actually gonna start with this one i
have sauce cups here
and these are gonna come into play i
probably should have made that more
sensual
no i shouldn't have you sick [ __ ] not
everything has to be
so goddamn horny with you
you need to cool it
i have pancake i'm actually going to
start with the uglier one and they're
cold now which is fantastic but we're
not judging this based on the pancake
even though i've made pancakes before i
think we all know i'm not good at that
just because i have a lot of ovens does
not mean that i'm good at cooking
so the reason i have sauce cups here is
because i'm gonna dip it because i don't
want it to get soggy and i don't want
the maple syrup to taint the rest of the
pancake
this makes sense
okay okay
it's a buttermilk pancake by the way
it's a buttermilk protein pancake by the
way because it tastes about the same
and you get a lot more protein with it i
like it you know
there's something about like a butter
syrup like mrs buttersworth that i
really just really like it's
thicker it has a strong flavor of butter
this is just pure maple syrup however
and i will say by itself
it is very good i don't know many people
that actually
don't like maple syrup however on a
preference side
this does not wow me enough to offset
the idea of
getting a mrs buttersworth type thing i
may try this with some butter
in it i will probably do that
butter mrs buttersworth does not tell me
any of her recipes so i really don't
know if this is the proper way to go
about it but now i've added butter so
butter flavored syrup is pretty much the
only thing that they say so
it's thicker
that tastes like butter and i like
butter okay so
i've now discovered the secret right if
you put butter in it
it tastes like butter honestly it's
quite good this would probably all be
better heated up too
but i mean cold pancakes by itself it's
definitely decent if i had to
choose between that and eating pancakes
dry of course of course i would go with
this
but this isn't a video about which is
better the corn syrup
vastly superior mrs buttersworth or
maple syrup this isn't a question about
that right
corn is always going to win corn versus
a tree
my money's on the corn right green giant
still hasn't sponsored me
like you know sometimes i just wonder
why i even bother
[Music]
like i work so hard to
just try to make my case for these
companies and i just sometimes
you know it i put myself out there
to be as honest and impartial in terms
of my reviews
as i can
and i guess just some people deserve
[Music]
sponsors and others don't so
so [ __ ] them that's what i say green
giant you're done
you're done so with me i'm gonna be
looking up a canadian alternative
and hey you lost your chance you had
your chance with me and you lost it so
you get out
you go with delmonte if that is their
real name
maybe you're the same person because you
treat me exactly the same so screw you
eat my ass and then go away
why did i say it like that god i gotta
work on my insults
all right done guy here
let's try this it's maple syrup
not really going to be a big surprise
here
definitely a lighter color i mean i'll
give it that it's definitely lighter
now i don't know what the original
tasted without the butter because my
tongue is coated with butter
i like that i think i like that better
it's slightly thicker than the other one
the other one's more it's not like it's
watery but it's just like this one's got
some more uh
consistency to it and i don't know if
it's like a mouth feel thing i have a
lot of mouth feel things i'm big on
mouth feel
like when i feel in my mouth i love the
feel of mouth
and like mouth feel is big for me if
there's things that are bad mouth feel i
don't exactly enjoy the mouth feel
those things and when i get the mouth
feel that i really am looking for
and that mouth feel really resonates in
my mouth and i can really feel it in my
mouth
i really enjoy those moments uh i think
i need to
like compare quickly i keep talking and
when i talk
like i forget everything i just sensed
in my mouth
like all the feeling is gone so i need
to move on this one says it's dark
robusto
like pizza
[Music]
there's a difference right it's kind of
there's definitely a difference here
this i get the robust
taste of it like they're all the same
kind of sweetness right they all still
have the same like amount of sugar
what's different in there is this one
like it's a darker color so i don't know
if that's just my brain kind of painting
it in that idea
but i definitely noticed like a stronger
sharper taste to it
i prefer this one to this one but like
the
difference is very subtle i'm sure that
canadians have a very refined palette
when it comes to maple syrup and they
can really discern these differences
because they've been eating it their
whole life you eat it drink it
whatever like but i can definitely tell
however i still pr this one's still my
favorite so far like i could drink this
out of a jug
i am drinking it out of a bottle but if
it was in jug form i would drink it out
of it
i'm not gonna drink it out of a jug i
don't drink mrs buttersworth out of a
jug if you know what i'm
jesus saying well i don't know what goes
on
in my head when i do these food reviews
it's like i'm
i'm a different person and i don't
understand why
it's like food with me i'm very like i'm
food motivated
i love food this is uh it just says
la epic it's it's
epic la epoch
this might be my favorite so far it's so
subtle like the difference is so
honestly truly very subtle but something
about this one it's not that it's sweet
or anything i'm not
going based on what sweeter i think
these all have the same amount of sugar
in them
because it's all still maple syrup but
there's something about this one
it's more
like flavorful right there's there's
flavor profiles to each of these they're
very similar but it's distinct right
i do like that i like that a lot the
maple syrup the only difference between
the maple trees is going to be like the
soil
the amount of sunlight they get the
sugar content the
region maybe air quality i don't even
know like that's going to be the only
difference between these it's like with
wine you know people [ __ ] about wine
all the time and they say they can tell
differences
that's basically what i'm doing here i'm
basically just bullshitting my way
through this so far
by the thinnest of margins i think this
one's my favorite
now we get to try the big the big
chungus
now this is the president's choice but
also i noticed that this one is also the
president's choice so i don't know if
this is just a big version of this
and if it is i'm gonna be very
disappointed in the president
of canada i don't think this was the
united states president's job
monk smells like maple syrup who'da
thunk
okay okay president's choice
hmm
[ __ ] christ they're the same
well you know they're all the same
because they're all maple syrup
but these are i i think these are the
same
to the president
i don't know what i was expecting right
look see make sure the brightness
matches through the whole video
very sure that these you couldn't see
through these before so bright brighten
it up a bit
more come on bring the brightness up
blast it come on blast me but make me
look good
make me look good perfect so yeah i
don't know what i was expecting
like they're all maple syrup i do think
i like this one the best
and that being said this was my previous
favorite so like obviously
this one's still good it's just in a big
fancy bottle it was thrown off by
marketing there's so many products out
there that have
exactly the same ingredients toothpaste
is the worst example of this like every
single toothpaste in every single
mouthwash
is almost exactly the same because the
only thing that really works
on repairing and fixing your teeth and
keeping them like strong is like sodium
fluoride so everything has the same
exact ingredient everything else doesn't
matter literally or unless it's
something like with sensodyne
i'll do a toothpaste review in the
future but like when it comes down to
this it's all just 100 pure maple syrup
really at the end of the day
it doesn't really matter like with wine
they all get you drunk like with this
it gets you through your day and now i'm
gonna get all this [ __ ]
from all the cast members others asleep
because
i opened all these and i barely touched
any of them
i'm sorry put up the artist rendition
i'm
sorry i'm very sorry
if you see them on the various social
medias
you tell them how sorry i am
don't tell them that you'll harass them
here's also the
the pancake that i made before
my best work yet
it's a little salty so that'll do it
for uh this food review um i don't have
a special surprise this time
because like it's maple syrup what am i
going to do
bust out another maple syrup
you guessed it i'm going to bust out
another maple syrup kaboom this maple
syrup unicorn
my fingers
i have neighbors and i'm sorry
i'm not sorry it's maple syrup sorry
so uh i was told that this is
the best maple syrup that you could
possibly
get it is just pure maple syrup that's
all it says
it doesn't say 100 pure but it's just
maple syrup and it's in a can like how
could you not it's like the same thing
with
the reason i went to canada before the
only other time i've been to canada
is because i heard that canada had
bagged milk so of
[ __ ] course me and my friends drove
up to canada
so this in the can now i don't really
have a can opener
but i don't think this is the kind of
thing that you would open with a can
opener anyway
um it's the kind of thing where you do
the punch hole in the
side old style can opener though
i'm gonna pour one out for my canadian
homies
ah the air hole and then i'm gonna
actually pour this on this pancake
i don't have a fork oh
that is actually different what the hell
[Music]
what the hell that is
actually very different not lying not
playing that up
i'd heard i was told that get get it in
the can
i don't know why it's in a can maybe
it's something to do with like glass and
maple syrup
or maybe it's just the metal from the
can leaching into it but this just goes
to show
canned anything is better than uncanned
nothing
not nothing everything else this is good
there's like a little bit of butteriness
to it
by itself
that is that's not just good that is
very good
and it's distinctly different it is
absolutely different
than these other ones these all were so
similar i could barely tell the
difference
this is night and day uh comparatively
different i don't know what else is
in here but am i crazy
like for those canadians watching am i
nuts about this
i was told this so maybe it's just my
brain like tricking myself
but this literally tastes different and
it's better
[Music]
i really like that that is my new
favorite there's something about it
that is distinctly different and now
everyone's going to be matt
well not everyone eve is going to be mad
at me for opening yet another
container but hey i'm mr buttersworth
when it comes to syrups i do what i want
so anyway that was my review of canada's
various maple syrups
thank you all so much for watching i
have many other reviews that i've done
through the link in the description
below none of which want to sponsor me
but if the maker of pure maple syrup
wants to give me a sponsorship and pay
me a butt load of money
i will gladly take it for the lovely
endorsement of your product that i have
already rendered
so basically you owe me
call my people they'll call your people
and we'll call each other's people and
don't talk to me directly ever
please and uh thank you all so much for
watching if you enjoyed this and want to
see more let me know down in the
comments below of other canadian things
that you would love to see me review
poutine is a suggestion but if you've
got other ones please
let me know i will give my unfiltered
honest opinion
of the various products and glorious
things that are available in canada
so thank you and as always i'll see you
in the next video bye bye
oh uh like comment subscribe whatever
yeah too late go
get it you lost your chance get you were
too late
what are you liking at the end of the
video you actually like when you watch
the video
get get the [ __ ] out get skid out
it's too late the subscribe button got
disabled it's too late
you're you're literally spilling into my
end card time
uh now they're popping up okay now the
video suggestions are popping up
you can click on those now you can get
out of here no don't even worry about it
you lost your chance snooze lose and you
lose and you snooze and you snooze to
lose
sorry love you bye